MALE SPEAKER: Good morning,
and welcome to Talks at google
in Cambridge, Massachusetts.
Today, it's my great pleasure to
introduce Dr. Angelo Volandes.
He joins us today to discuss his
new book, "The Conversation-- A
Revolutionary Plan
For End-of-Life Care."
Dr. Volandes believes
that a life well
lived deserves a good ending.
Through the stories of seven
patients with very different
end-of-life experiences,
he demonstrates
that what seriously
ill people who
are approaching the
end of their lives
need most is not
new technologies,
but one simple thing,
"the conversation."
He argues for a
radical re-envisioning
of the patient-doctor
relationship,
and offers ways for
patients and their families
to talk about this
difficult issue
to ensure that patients
will be in charge
of their medical care.
Dr. Volandes is a
physician and researcher
at Harvard Medical School
and Mass General Hospital.
He's the Co-founder of Advanced
Care Planning Decisions,
a nonprofit organization devoted
to encouraging the conversation
through the use of videos.
Please join me in
welcoming Dr. Volandes.
ANGELO VOLANDES:
So good morning.
Thanks a lot for coming.
I really appreciate it.
It's a real privilege to present
some of the work that I do,
and especially here at
Google, because you all
tackle some of the most
difficult problems facing
our society.
And what I'm going
to talk about today
is what I feel is the most
urgent problem in health care
today.
So maybe you can help
me think about it.
When we asked most people
where do they want to die,
where do they tell us?
AUDIENCE: Home.
ANGELO VOLANDES: Home.
Most Americans want
to die at home.
In fact, in the latest
survey, 86% of Americans
want to die at home,
surrounded by their loved ones,
and in comfort.
But what are the facts?
Where do most people die
in our country today?
AUDIENCE: Hospitals.
ANGELO VOLANDES: Hospitals.
People over the age
of 65, 2/3 of them
will die in a
hospital or nursing
home, often tethered to a
machine and in a good deal
of pain and suffering.
This misalignment between the
type of medical care people
want and the type of
medical care they end up
getting in our health
care system today
is what I feel is the most
urgent problem in health care.
Now, you've all been
reading about it.
On the front page of
"The New York Times"
there's been a story
about the problem.
And we usually talk about
it in terms of cost.
Yes, end-of-life care
is, indeed, costly.
But by the end of
our time together, I
hope to throw in two other
phrases, two other lenses
from which to
understand this problem.
When Americans get
care in hospitals
that if they were more
informed they would not want,
let's call it for what it
is-- it's unwanted care.
And when people get unwanted
care in our health care system
today, it's truly
a medical error.
It's no different than
a surgeon operating
on the wrong side of the body,
or an ICU doctor not following
a checklist for a patient
on a breathing machine.
But we don't want to
just talk about problems.
What are some
potential solutions?
For me, I feel that
the primary reason
why people get unwanted care
in our health care system today
is because doctors are not
slowing down, sitting down,
and having the conversation--
an honest and frank discussion
with patients and family members
about what's important to them.
But, you know, today we live
in a visually-literate society.
We're a YouTube generation,
and that's true of all ages.
And sometimes words
are not enough.
Sometimes we need images to
help people better understand
their options.
So I'm also going
to talk about how
to enhance those
conversations with videos.
But before I get
started, I thought
I'd begin with a story-- this
is, after all, a book reading.
Meet Professor Helen Thompson.
Helen Thompson was one of
the foremost literary critics
on the poetry of Walt Whitman.
How many of you are
familiar with the poetry
of Walt Whitman?
Great.
So there's definitely a
generational gap there.
I was born and bred in
Brooklyn, New York-- you'll
hear my accent occasionally--
where Walt Whitman spent
the first half of his life.
So every other street corner
had a Whitman Elementary School,
and all the pupils
were forced to memorize
the opening lines of
Whitman's magnum opus,
"The Leaves of Grass."
So Professor Thompson
and I hit it off
because we could both
recite those lines.
"I celebrate myself
and sing myself.
And what I assume
you shall assume,
for every atom belonging to
me as good, belongs to you."
Now, you may be
asking yourself why
I'm telling you about Helen
Thompson or the poetry of Walt
Whitman.
Well, what I haven't told
you is that Helen Thompson
was my patient a few years ago.
What I haven't told you
is that Helen Thompson
was a 56-year-old female with
brain cancer being admitted
to my hospital service.
What I haven't told you is
that Helen Thompson was dying.
And so I conducted a history.
I did my physical exam.
And then I got to
that point where
doctors get a little
bit uncomfortable with,
where the words of Whitman
metamorphosed into other words.
Words like CPR, ventilators,
the ICU, goals of care, hospice.
In other words,
the vocabulary of
shared decision-making
at the end of life.
And I looked at the professor
and I said, "Professor,
you've seen scores
of doctors since you
were diagnosed, and by the
time that you're seeing me.
Have you ever had the
conversation with them?"
And she gave me
that blank stare.
And so I proceeded to
ask her those questions.
What's important to you?
What's a good day for you?
Where did you want to spend
whatever remaining time you
have?
Where are you on this
journey with your illness?
And then she looked at me
and give me that blank stare
that I think a lot of
patients give doctors when
they have this conversation.
And so I naively asked
her, I said, "Professor,
would you take a walk with
me to the Intensive Care Unit
so I can actually show
you some of these things?"
Of course she obliged.
We didn't walk to the ICU.
I put her in a wheelchair
and rolled her down
to the Intensive Care Unit.
I got to show her a ventilator.
I got to show her a patient
on a breathing machine.
There were a couple
of residents there.
One was performing
a lumbar puncture,
another one was
inserting a central line.
And what the professor
was able to do
was to get a sense of the
place-- hear the beeps
and buzzes, see the
colorful monitors,
to feel the rhythm of
the Intensive Care Unit.
Now, as fate would have it-- I
obviously did not plan on this,
but there was a code blue in
the ICU while we were there,
and I immediately brought her
out of the Intensive Care Unit,
but not before she caught
a few glimpses of CPR.
When we went back to her
room, she looked at me
and said, "Words, words, words.
Angelo, I understood
every single word
that you said before.
CPR, breathing
machines, comfort care.
I am, after all, a
professor of English.
But I had no idea that's
what you were talking about.
It doesn't look like
that on television."
And that's when
it occurred to me,
so often health care, we're
having these conversations
with our patients
and family members,
but they're thinking about
what's on the television
and that CPR works all the
time, and that everybody
looks like George Clooney
on a breathing machine.
The clinical reality
is very different.
So what I decided to do was to
take my next six patients, all
with a serious illness,
and their families
on their own personal
tour of our hospital.
Some patients I brought to
our Intensive Care Unit.
Other patients and families I
brought to our dialysis unit.
And what every
person told me was
that this was the most powerful
and empowering experience
that they had ever had.
That they couldn't
imagine making
a decision about end-of-life
care without this tour.
Now, although the
nurses loved what
I was doing-- they could see
the educational value in it--
they quickly put an end
to my tour business.
Because they knew I was breaking
patient confidentiality.
So here's the conundrum
that I was left with.
How could I recreate this
powerful and empowering
experience for both
patients and families,
and yet not break
patient confidentiality?
And that's when I came
up with the idea--
why not create short films
to help people better
understand their options.
So it's not just me.
It's a group of
around 100 of us.
We are 100 doctors,
nurses, patients, families,
and video artists from 10
academic medical centers
who create these short videos.
But we don't just
create them, we actually
study them in rigorous,
randomized control trials.
And there's three
things that we find.
First, for patients who
have a serious illness
and watch a video, they're more
informed about their options.
They have much more knowledge
with which to understand
their medical options.
The second thing
is that for people
who have a serious illness
who have a conversation
and use a video,
they actually tend
to want more
comfort-oriented care.
They make decisions
that lead them
to end-of-life care
outside of the hospital,
not tethered to
machines, and not
in our Intensive Care Units.
And the third thing is
when we asked people,
are you comfortable watching
a video about goals of care
at the end-of-life, people are
overwhelmingly comfortable.
We truly are a YouTube
generation where
people expect these images.
If a picture speaks
thousand words,
videos speak hundreds
of thousands of words.
So what I thought I'd do is
show you one of our studies.
And it was actually our
first study done right here
at Massachusetts General
Hospital with patients
who had advanced cancer.
So what we did is we
took 50 patients, all
with advanced cancer, and
we randomized the group
into two groups.
The first group had
a verbal discussion
about what sort of medical
care they wanted now
that they had advanced cancer.
We asked them, what
would you want now
that you have advanced cancer,
and we gave them three options.
The other half of the group
had the same verbal discussion,
but then they saw a short
video that actually showed them
what each of their
goals of care entailed.
Now, I know most of you
are not clinicians, but let
me just give you the general
flavor of the goals of care.
This is available
anywhere in America today.
You generally have
three options.
Life-prolonging care, limited
care, and comfort care.
And I'll briefly
review each one.
With life-prolonging care,
the goal is to prolong life.
It includes anything available
in a modern day hospital--
CPR, breathing machines,
the Intensive Care Unit.
The middle category,
limited care,
is essentially hospitalization
without the ICU, without CPR.
And the third
category, comfort care,
is essentially symptom relief,
really hospice level care.
So those are the options
that all 50 patients had.
But for the patients that
were randomized to the video,
they got to see
visual images of each
of those categories of care.
Now, the particular video that
we created for these patients
was a seven minute video, and
it was filmed and developed
with an expert panel
of over 50 oncologists,
intensivists, palliative
care doctors, nurses,
social workers, chaplains,
patients with advanced cancer,
and the families of patients
with advanced cancer.
We wanted to make
sure that we offered
a fair and impartial
portrayal of what
the options were for patients.
Now, dealing with 50 people,
we bent over backwards
to make sure that we
addressed everybody's concern.
But you know the joke about
getting a bunch of oncologists
together and asking them
an opinion on a patient,
you'll get 50
different opinions.
This video took us
two years to make.
Steven Spielberg makes probably
five films in two years.
But we wanted to make sure that
patients and providers felt
that this was a fair
and impartial portrayal.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I'm Angelo Volandes, a
Physician at Harvard Medical
School.
Thank you for taking the time
to read "THE Conversation."
It's been a privilege
caring for patients.
Thank you for hearing their
stories and bearing witness.
In this video I'll be
covering some of the topics
that I touch on in
the book, so make
sure to refer to the book for
more details and information.
Talking about medical
care at the end of life
can sometimes be
difficult, but it doesn't
have to be a sad conversation.
There's a common three-step
approach to do it well.
The three steps are
start the process
and have the conversation.
Talk to your loved
ones about your values
and what's important to you.
And then talk to
your health care team
about your medical choices.
Let's review each
one of these steps
so you can make sure you get
the right care at the right time
and on your own terms.
Don't wait for your doctor
to start the conversation.
Start the discussion on your
own with family and friends.
Here are four questions that
can help start the process.
What kinds of things are
most important to you?
What concerns do you have
about getting sick or needing
medical care?
If you were very sick, are there
any specific medical treatments
that might be too much for you?
And finally, what
are your spiritual,
philosophical, religious,
or cultural beliefs
that would influence
your medical decisions?
Considering these questions
is only the beginning.
These reflections are not a
one-time event, but a process
that you should
return to over time.
After you've thought about
your values and wishes,
it's important to share your
information with your loved
ones.
Holidays are a good time to
start having these discussions
with the people you
would want to be around
if you became very sick.
Pick a calm and
quiet place to talk.
The talk doesn't have to
have a certain structure,
let it just happen.
And you don't need to
establish everything
with one conversation.
After the conversation
I often tell my patients
to use their cell phone or
tablet to film themselves
telling their loved ones what
is most important in their lives
regarding medical care.
They can then send
the video to them.
And if you are ready,
complete the appropriate legal
paperwork.
Now you're ready to complete
the last step, talking
with your health care team.
Talking with your
doctor is vital,
since he or she will know
your medical condition best
and will be able
to help translate
your preferences into an
actionable medical plan.
There are three
general approaches
to medical care for
people who are very sick.
They are life-prolonging
care, limited medical care
and comfort care.
The first approach is
life-prolonging care.
With this option the
focus is to lengthen life.
This includes all medical
care that is available
in the hospital like
CPR, breathing machines,
and treatments in the ICU.
For healthy people, CPR has
a good chance of success
and has improved over time.
However, for people with
an advanced illness,
CPR's overall
effectiveness is not high.
It's important to
ask your doctor
what the chances are that CPR
will work in someone like you.
Sometimes people decide to try
life-prolonging interventions
for a short period of time.
And if the interventions
are not successful
they move to the next
option, limited medical care.
With limited medical
care, the focus
is to take care of
treatable problems.
People who choose this
approach want medical care that
will help restore their health.
My father received
limited medical care.
He had IV medications
with careful monitoring.
But he did not want any
life-prolonging interventions
like CPR and breathing machines.
He chose to avoid
these procedures,
even though he might
have died without them.
The third approach
is comfort care.
With comfort care, the main
goal is to be comfortable.
Treatments are only used if they
help make people feel better
and improve their
quality of life.
People who choose this
approach are usually
treated at home, in hospice,
or sometimes in a nursing home.
Talk to your doctor
and your loved ones.
If you let them
know your choices,
they can help make
sure that you are
at the center of and in
control of your care.
Thank you for taking
this journey with me
and hearing the lives of
some extraordinary people.
Their stories are our stories.
Take care.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ANGELO VOLANDES: What did
those 50 patients, what
were their decisions?
So let's take a look
at the group that
only had a verbal discussion.
In yellow we have
life-prolonging care.
In blue we have limited care.
And in green we
have comfort care.
So why don't you take a guess
of what you think people wanted.
Charles, what do you think
people in the verbal arm felt?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ANGELO VOLANDES: What percentage
wanted life-prolonging care?
AUDIENCE: About 65%.
ANGELO VOLANDES: 65% wanted
life-prolonging care.
This is what we found.
26% in yellow wanted
life-prolonging care.
52% in blue wanted limited care.
And 22% wanted
comfort-oriented care.
I'll be honest.
I admit these patients to
the hospital all the time.
I wasn't surprised by this.
The patients that I admit to the
hospital with advanced cancer,
I'd say a quarter want
life-prolonging care,
a quarter want
comfort-oriented care.
Half the people are
somewhere in between.
Well, what happened to the group
that actually saw the video?
The gentleman with the green
t-shirt, what do you think?
AUDIENCE: A sharp
decline in life
prolonging care and shifting
down to comfort care,
so call it 10, 40 and 50.
ANGELO VOLANDES: A sharp
decline in life prolonging care,
an increase in comfort care,
10% life prolonging care,
40% limited care, and
the rest comfort care.
Well, let's take a look at
what our patients chose.
A dramatic difference.
The interesting thing was that
the people who saw the video
also had more knowledge.
We actually quizzed them
and they answered many more
questions correctly after
watching the video compared
to patients who did
not watch the video.
So what this told us was
if you saw the video,
you had more
knowledge and you were
more likely to choose
comfort oriented care.
Now to be clear, when we have
verbal discussions today,
what happens?
Most people still end up
dying in our hospitals.
2/3 of folks are dying
in our hospitals.
That's what's going on today.
But can we imagine a time when
people are more informed, where
they had the
conversation, they have
a video that explains
their options
and standardizes the process.
What happens then?
Most people die outside
of the health care system,
surrounded by their loved
ones and in comfort.
This is the medical emergency of
our lifetime in the health care
system today.
We are delivering unwanted
care every single day
in our hospitals and nursing
homes across the country.
It's a medical error.
So this study was done close
to the seven, eight years ago.
Since then we've
done many studies
and the interesting thing is
we're seeing the same things.
So I'm just going to give
you a quick glimpse of what
some of our other work shows.
We asked 200 elderly
people what sort of medical
care they would want if they had
advanced Alzheimer's disease.
And we did the same study.
Randomized control trial.
Half of them had a
verbal description.
The other half had a verbal
description plus saw a video.
Here's what the group that
only had a verbal description,
this is what they told us.
19% wanted life prolonging care.
17% wanted limited care.
And 64% in green
wanted comfort care.
What happened to the group that
had the same verbal description
and then saw a video?
A very different
picture emerges.
86% of people wanted
comfort oriented care.
We even went to a
primary care clinic
and did the same
study asking people,
if you had a serious illness,
what sort of medical care would
you want?
In the group that only
had a verbal discussion,
72% of people wanted
comfort oriented care.
Add the video and
all of a sudden, that
jumps up to 91% of people.
Not a single person
wanted aggressive life
prolonging care.
We even went to nursing homes.
And this is something really
near and dear to my heart
because I'm not
only a doctor, I'm
also a son who's dealing
with this with his parents
as we speak.
So let's take a look
at a nursing home.
Same study.
Half of people were
asked, how do you want,
what are your goals of care?
How do you want to spend
the end of your life?
In a skilled nursing
facility, right here--
these were two facilities
right here in Boston-- 57%
wanted comfort oriented care.
What happens when
people actually
watch a video that explains to
them what their options are?
That number increases to 80%.
But even that wasn't enough.
We went to our medical ICU right
here at Massachusetts General
Hospital and we asked,
not the patients
because they were
too sick, in fact,
all the patients were intubated.
They were on a
breathing machine.
So we asked their families
to make a decision about CPR.
And these were all
critically ill patients
who had a terminal diagnosis.
And this is what
the families told us
about CPR when we described
to them the procedure.
78% of people in red wanted CPR
attempted on their loved ones.
What happens when you actually
show people what CPR involves?
That number drops to 41%.
We live in the
health care system
that does not do a good
job of communicating
with patients and families.
And we've now done trials
in over 2,000 people
all across the country.
But it's not enough
to show that people
are more informed
with videos or to show
that they make decisions
about comfort oriented care.
You have to show that people
actually like the videos.
So we asked all
2,000 subjects, what
did you think about the video?
This is what people told us.
90% of people who viewed
the video found it helpful.
But were they comfortable
watching the video?
93% of people were very
comfortable watching the video.
And then I think the
gold standard question
as a doctor is asking my
patient who has seen the video,
would you recommend
this to your mom or dad
or to a sibling who has to
make a similar decision?
97% of people said they would.
When did 97% of patients
ever agree on anything?
These are really high
numbers, as you can imagine.
I think it just
speaks to the fact
that we are a visually
literate society.
Our patients and families
are now expecting this.
So I could have stopped
and done my research.
I would've gotten on my
way to getting tenured
at Harvard Medical School.
Wonderful.
Sit on my derriere at
Massachusetts General Hospital.
But our group didn't want
to just make publications.
We didn't want to have this
work really just in libraries
and read by a bunch of doctors.
We are interested in
transforming health care.
So three years ago,
I co-founded along
with another colleague who's
both a doctor and a lawyer,
we co-founded a
nonprofit foundation
whose mission is to transform
health care across the country
by using videos.
And as of today, there are
200 hospitals, clinics,
nursing homes, hospices,
and health care systems
across the country
in nearly 25 states
who use our videos to
transform the medical culture
in their health care system.
Think Khan Academy
but for medicine.
And it's probably the
most exciting work
that I do because for
too long we've just
been talking about the problem.
We haven't been posing
solutions to what
to do about this unwanted
care in our health care system
today.
Now our library of
videos has exploded.
We have over 60 videos
because we not only make
videos for the leading
causes of death,
cancer, heart failure, dementia,
but also in all the languages
that represent our
diverse community.
So we have videos and Spanish,
Cantonese, Mandarin, Japanese,
Korean, Vietnamese, Tagalog,
Ilokano, Marshallese,
even Samoan because
what we're trying to do
is to meet people
where they're at.
Our latest series of videos
are actually in Persian
because we found a great
need in the Persian community
to actually make sure people
understand their options.
But I know we're at Google
and it's all about data.
So we are also
interested in big data.
And what we wanted to ask
is do these videos actually
make a large difference?
Sure, you could try to attack
200 hospitals and clinics
across the country,
but what about
an entire geographic area.
So our nonprofit is
now involved in one
of the largest
projects in America
when it comes to
end of life care.
And what we've decided is
to blanket an entire state,
the wonderful Aloha
state of Hawaii,
where all 1.4 million
residents have access
to all of our videos.
Over the course of three
years-- we're about halfway
through-- every single
resident of Hawaii
has access to the videos.
15 hospitals, 50 skilled
nursing facilities, 10 hospices,
over 600 providers,
regardless of your insurance,
regardless of where you're
seen in the entire state,
you have access to a
video, in your language,
that will allow you to
understand your options.
And what we're doing is
using very large databases
to see, over the course
of three years, what
happens to hospitalizations.
What happens to the number
of deaths in the hospital?
What happens to number of days
in the ICU before people die?
And we're going to use those
metrics to see, can a video
and prioritizing the
conversation at an entire state
wide level, can you really
transform health care?
We've already started
getting the data
and I'm pleased to
say that indeed, we're
seeing transformation already.
In fact, four other
very large states
are interested in replicating
what we're doing in Hawaii.
Because that's what
this is all about.
It's making sure
that patients get
the right care at the right
time, but on their terms.
Today, although we say we live
in a patient centered health
care system, I think
many of you know
we don't live in a patient
centered health care system.
We live in a clinician
centric health care
system, where people
end up getting
"care," that if they were more
informed, they wouldn't want.
Now before I end, I
thought I would tell you
about my own journey
to this work.
And so I thought I just
take a 10 minute book
reading, since we are
at a book reading,
of telling you about
my very first patient.
Taras Skripchenko was a living
part of American history.
As I later found out, Taras
was an ethnic Ukrainian
who had emigrated to the United
States from the Soviet Union
as an adolescent.
He was one of the
lucky few who escaped
the chaos that took over during
the months before World War II.
Taras wanted to start over,
to rewrite the opening
chapters of his life.
At 18, he found a new home
in a Ukrainian enclave
in one of the mining
towns of Appalachia
and quickly found labor
in the coal mines.
For years he led a life of
unremitting physical toil,
working 12 hour shifts,
six days a week.
Unfortunately for Taras,
a lot of the detritus
from smashing coal
dug its way deep
into the lining of his
lungs, plugging the airways.
It would also plant the creeping
cancer that would devastate him
decades later.
This once hulking
mine worker had
dwindled to a mere whisper
of his former muscular self.
This frail,
bed-bound 78-year-old
with inoperable lung cancer was
admitted to my medical service
during my first year
of residency training.
Slowly suffocating to
death, he experienced
both transient moments
of hallucinatory
joy and unconscious,
yet peaceful somnolence
on the oncology ward.
Taras was too confused to
have a lucid conversation
and lacked family members to
guide his decision making,
so his medical plan was
the default approach
for all patients.
Do everything.
Despite my efforts to come
up with a plan for Taras,
I knew that his cancer
surely had a plan of its own.
Doctors can fool
themselves into thinking
that they are in charge, even
when disease and pathology are
in the driver's seat.
Frequently, we are only
along for the ride.
Taras was dying.
I knew it and the
nurses knew it.
But as far as the medical
team was concerned,
Taras was a full code.
If his heart or lungs
stopped working,
we would attempt CPR and place
him on a breathing machine.
Exhausted from a long day, I
paged the overnight resident
to meet me in the cafeteria
to review my patients before I
signed out.
The overnight doctor was a
senior resident named Edward
and I was glad an
experienced resident was
on call that night.
I told the resident
to keep a close watch
on Taras Skripchenko.
He's a Ukrainian gentleman.
He worked in the coal
mines of Appalachia.
About eight months ago,
he started having a cough.
He saw as primary care doctor
who ordered a chest x-ray.
Stop right there, Edward said.
Start again.
Start with initials
and then in one line,
give me the pertinent info.
Less is more.
I have 30 other patients
to cover tonight.
When a resident is responsible
for 30 patients at night,
too many personal details
can muddle one's thinking.
TS is a 78-year-old male patient
with metastatic lung cancer who
presented with shortness
of breath and delirium,
I said, he's really sick.
Modern medicine
can be dehumanizing
and the first step
in that process
is to remove all the
individualized details.
To obliterate personhood
and replace it
with patienthood, where
two letters are a patient's
diagnosis, treatment,
and prognosis.
Code blue.
Edward and I sprinted
towards the oncology ward,
racing through the
obstacle course
of stretchers and patients.
We finally arrived, out of
breath, at Taras's room.
I was always taught
to hope for the best
but prepare for the worst before
entering a patient's room.
But it's not always clear
how to define the worst.
The gathered nurses who
had ordered the code blue
had already started CPR.
I clumsily jammed my hands
into a pair of rubber gloves
and joined the
ritual, relieving one
of the nurses doing
chest compressions, which
is far more physically
demanding and brutal than what
is portrayed on television.
My clasped hands pressed hard
against Taras's frail chest
and all I could here and feel
were the cracking of his ribs
with practically each
chest compression.
The rhythmic pumping on his
chest eerily emitted a coarse.
Velcro like sound.
Edward stood at
the foot of the bed
and took charge,
directing what was
likely to be Taras's
passage from life.
I searched for a
pulse on Taras's neck.
Any fat had melted
away long ago and all
I could feel was
cartilage and wind pipe.
It's an eerie feeling,
sliding bloody gloved fingers
along the skin, searching
for signs of life.
Shockingly, I found
only a thready pulse,
one that lacked vigor.
Taras was stabilized.
He was connected to
a breathing machine
and had a pulse with
a normal rhythm.
The team had saved
the patient and now it
was time to transfer
him to the ICU.
Edward and I bundled Taras
and his machines onto a gurney
and navigated the labyrinth
of hallways to the elevator.
We squeezed into
the narrow elevator.
As the doors closed, I kept my
hand on Taras's carotid artery,
making sure to feel
for a pulse until I
realized he no longer had one.
There was no space
alongside the gurney,
so I jumped on, straddled
him, and started
performing chest compressions.
In all likelihood, the cancer
had spread to the thin sack
around his heart, allowing
blood and fluid to seep in
and surround the vigorously
pumping heart muscle.
To get the heart
beating again, a doctor
must emergently stick a large
needle into the patient's chest
and draw out the fluid.
We needed to move fast.
Do you feel
comfortable doing this?
Edward asked.
I told him that I had
performed the procedure
on a cadaver in anatomy
class, but I'd only
seen one on a patient.
See one, do one, teach one.
Here's your chance
on a warm body,
he rejoined, as
the elevator doors
opened to a crowd of
nurses ready to wheel
the patient towards the ICU.
I descended from the gurney.
Edward handed me a large
syringe, attached to a needle
the length of my ring finger.
I stared at the needle.
My hands were shaking,
not surprising
since I was about to poke around
a man's heart with a needle.
You don't know how deep to
slide the needle into the body
in order to draw out the
fluid from the sac surrounding
the heart.
Every body is different.
Some are fatter
than others and some
are more muscular than fat.
I pierced Taras's skin
just below the sternum
and carefully pushed the
needle through the skin,
simultaneously pulling
back on the syringe,
hoping to see fluid.
No luck.
The tremulousness in my hands
worsened and beads of sweat
trickled down my forehead,
falling onto the syringe.
I advanced the needle a
little more, but no luck.
I pulled needle out and tried
again and again and again.
By the fourth time, I gave up.
Residents are usually
allowed three strikes
before being asked to stop.
Edward gave me a fourth
since this was my patient.
I probably should have
stopped after the third.
Taras's ribcage had become a pin
cushion from all my attempts.
As soon as we entered
the ICU, Edward
filled in the medical
team as they took over,
using the ultrasound machine to
remove the liquid surrounding
his heart.
Taras's once flailing
heart could beat again.
He had a pulse.
Taras's care was now being
managed by the ICU team,
so Edward and I headed
back to the cafeteria
to grab some coffee.
After every code blue,
the team is expected
to review what transpired.
It's a ritualized moment
to grapple with the trauma
surrounding a full on code.
Debriefings are always
difficult moments
as each of us dials down the
rapid pace of a code blue
to digest the events that
have just transpired.
We sat quietly
for a few minutes.
We reviewed the
running of the code,
how each team member had
performed his or her duties,
we replayed each of
the interventions
I had performed and
discussed how I could improve
my technique for the next time.
Silence settled again once
the routine items were out
of the way.
But there was more to be said.
We just completed
by the book code
but I wonder if we
did them right thing,
I said, needing to tell
Edward what was on my mind.
Perhaps it was because
I was a young doctor
and I had not yet been numbed to
the brutal experience of caring
for hundreds of patients.
I hoped Edward, a
more seasoned doctor,
would have a better perspective.
We did exactly what
we were taught to do.
Everything was by the book.
Look, this is the system.
We have a job to do, he said.
But I could see a slight
unease in his face,
a hint of upheaval.
We both knew something
was not right.
I can't believe we
just did all that
to a man who has one foot
in the grave, I pushed,
not mincing my words.
Would he have
wanted any of this?
Would you have
Would you do this to your dad?
Something is wrong
with a health care
system that puts terminal
cancer patients through torture.
Edward put a hand
on my shoulder.
It's going to be all right.
You're still new at this.
You'll get used to it.
Get some sleep and
page me tomorrow.
Get used to this?
Is one supposed to
get used to this?
Over the next two
days, Edward and I
followed Taras every
few hours in the ICU.
He was no longer our
patient but we could not
let go of him either.
By the following morning,
he had a tube or catheter
in almost every
part of his body.
A grand total of eight plastic
intrusions, Taras was fixed.
Doctors like to tackle
problems and fix them.
And it is truly amazing
what modern medicine
has achieved in a relatively
brief span of time.
The tougher issue,
however, is when
to recognize that the
small fixes do not
change the larger picture.
To recognize that fixing
specific problems may not
fix the whole patient.
This is medicine's
version of not seeing
the forest for the trees.
Doctors always search
for the next fix.
But we need to know when to
use or not to use our growing
toolkit of fixes.
Taras's heart had
stopped three more times
and miraculously, the ICU team
had brought him back each time.
But not surprisingly, a
patient in the late stages
of terminal cancer
succumbed to his disease.
Whatever the next new
fixes, nature eventually
takes her inexorable course.
Taras died 48 hours after
that initial code blue.
Americans receive some of the
best health care money can buy.
They also experience some of the
worst deaths in the developed
world.
The primary reason we
experience such horrible deaths
is doctors' failure to
openly discuss medical care
with seriously ill patients.
Taras Skripchenko
died 15 years ago.
I have since witnessed
hundreds of deaths
but his, which I experienced
during the formative years
of my medical
residency, haunted me
for the first decade of my
life as a young physician.
So too did that
conversation with Edward,
as we both struggled to
make sense of the drama that
had just unfolded before us.
Today I am a full
fledged medical doctor,
a senior physician,
and teacher of others,
yet I still think about Taras
each time I meet a new patient.
A new beginning, a clean
slate, but also a potential TS.
Thank you very much.
So we have allowed
some time for Q&A.
And what I was
encouraged to do is
to have you come on
up to the microphones
because this is being recorded.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for doing
this very important work.
I could ask a lot of
questions but let me ask one
about data, basically.
I am interested in
how you're actually
measuring the outcomes of
your video intervention.
In the first series of
studies you described,
you described those
as randomized trials
but the outcome you were
measuring there was simply,
as I understand it, just
that people then told you
what they would prefer.
Now in your Hawaii study,
which you mentioned,
obviously a much
more massive study,
you clearly are aiming to
measure actual outcomes
in terms of what kind of
care these people got,
but from the way
you described it,
it sounds like you're using
more of an epidemiological model
that there is not a
randomization component there.
So I'm curious about
how you're going
to extricate the effects
of your intervention
from all the other stuff.
Are you just going to use
standard statistical techniques
to do that or do you have an
actual randomized component
somewhere where you're
actually looking
at what the outcomes were and
not just what people told you
at the end of the studies.
ANGELO VOLANDES: What
a wonderful question.
I wish I had more time to tell
you about all of our studies,
but let me tell you about three
that address that exact point.
So just last week a
study was published
in the "Journal of General
Internal Medicine" where
we not only looked at
what people told us,
we actually looked at
what happened over time
through the electronic
medical record.
And we found three things
which were fascinating.
Again, same thing,
randomized control trial.
Half of people got the
usual care at our hospital.
The other half of people had
usual care plus the video.
And we actually found
the following abstracted
from the electronic
medical record.
People actually
made real decisions
after watching
the video that was
for not having the aggressive
life prolonging interventions.
The other thing we found, what
there was actual documentation
of doctors having
the conversation
and stating that they
had the conversation.
Written documentation.
But we went even
one step further.
We actually followed
people for one year
and what we found was that
patients in both arms,
the first group that did not
watch the video-- I forgot
the number of people, maybe
40 or something people--
were readmitted to the hospital.
And what we found was
that 22% of people
ended up getting an intervention
that they never wanted,
that they actually told us.
What percentage do
you think in the arm
that saw the video got
something that they didn't want?
AUDIENCE: Zero.
ANGELO VOLANDES: 2%.
And that person was
actually someone
who had a procedure done and
it was temporarily reversed.
So what we have
for the first time
is hard data of real decisions
of people showing exactly
what the previous study shows.
But that's not enough.
I'm with you.
That's a small study
at two hospitals.
What we're doing in
Hawaii is the next step,
which is we're doing
a natural experiment.
We actually know when
we started in Hawaii
in terms of the videos.
So what we're doing at time 0
when the videos were started
and we know the
penetration rates.
It's not like all of
a sudden everybody
and Hawaii is
watching the videos.
It's graduated over time.
So over the course
of three years--
three years is our
point-- at that point,
we're actually going to compare
hospitalization rates, hospital
deaths, ICU deaths,
chemotherapy in the last life,
compared to three years
before we started in Hawaii.
Furthermore, we know what's
going on in the state.
So we will account for those
through statistical methods.
But even that is not enough.
Our biggest project today,
which I didn't mention,
is looking at a randomized
cluster trial, which
is called a pragmatic trial.
This is all fancy words of just
saying, instead of randomizing
by the unit of the patient,
why not randomize 600 nursing
homes all across the country.
Half of the nursing
homes get usual care.
That data is collected through
a large database called MDS.
And then the other
half of nursing homes,
the other few
hundred, will actually
get to use the videos
after being trained
and however they wish.
And what we're going to
do is to see over time
those hard outcomes
that we talked about.
That's truly the
randomized control trial
that you're asking about.
But we've moved beyond
the data that I've
shown which is more of what do
people tell us to hard data.
What happens.
Because we feel that this
work will truly transform care
where using large
databases now we
have the opportunity to do that.
And I should mention that the
nursing home study is actually
funded by the NIH, the
National Institutes of Health.
Thank you for that
great question.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming.
So when you talked
about the video
showing the comfort
level, when you
talk with people in
nursing homes about that,
how does that-- they're in
a nursing home, which is not
at home with family and things.
Do you adjust that?
Or how is that
presented to them?
ANGELO VOLANDES:
Wonderful question.
And in fact, we
developed a video
for that study with the nursing
homes, just on this point.
People don't realize just
because you live in a nursing
home, in a skilled nursing
facility, if you're
a resident there, what is the
assumption of most people?
I get sick, I'm going to
go back to the hospital.
That's not true.
There are many
things that could be
done focused on quality of
life and comfort oriented care
right there in the nursing home.
And so people actually do have
the option of hospice care
at a nursing facility.
It's one of the
newer waves of what
we're seeing in skilled
nursing facilities
because let me tell
you, as a doctor
and what I see here all
the time is the revolving
door of the hospital.
We get a frail
elderly person who's
admitted to the nursing home.
No one has had the conversation.
No one has started
the process of talking
with the family, what's
important to them,
what do they want to focus on.
And as soon as they
get a fever, as soon
as they become
delirious, they're just,
and I hate to use the word--
shipped to the hospital.
Call 911 at the nursing home.
The ambulance comes.
Nobody has asked the patient
or the family what they want
and they're brought
to the hospital.
That fix that we do in
the hospital, antibiotics,
get the patient back
to where they were,
and then they're shipped right
back to the nursing home.
It happens thousands
of times a day.
And it's because in
nursing facilities,
we're not having
the conversation.
No one's explaining to people
what their options are.
And that's that sort
of disruptive nature
of the videos.
The idea behind the videos is
that today, I'm the doctor,
I have all the power.
If we're going to
talk about this,
it's only because
I raise this issue.
And most of the time, I'm
not raising this issue.
What we're hoping the videos
do is empower patients
and families so they know
what their options are.
So that they know
what are the questions
they should be
asking themselves.
This way we're not relying
on the health care system
to bring up these questions.
Patients and families are
bringing up this question.
And, in fact, that
study that I mentioned,
what we found was that
patients indeed were asking
their doctors, hey, I
just saw a video that
mentioned my options for care.
I want to talk
about this with you.
I have much more
faith in relying
on patients and families
to raise this question
by empowering them
with videos than I
do on the health care system.
It's disruptive because
it flips the power dynamic
and I hope that the video,
which is on YouTube,
it's at theconversationbook.org.
I hope that people use
it to empower themselves.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
also for your work.
Four really short questions.
ANGELO VOLANDES: Four
really short questions.
Let's go one by one.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Where can we get the videos?
Can we get them online?
Two does it make a difference--
ANGELO VOLANDES: So
the first question,
theconversationbook.org.
It's a short video.
It tells you through all your
questions and your options.
Your second question.
AUDIENCE: Is the video without
the conversation as effective
as the video with
the conversation?
ANGELO VOLANDES: Great question.
What we've done in
all of our studies
is not only done the
video in isolation.
This is meant to supplement
"The Conversation."
So it's always been
Conversation, Conversation
plus video.
And I truly feel that at the end
of the day, videos are a tool.
The answer and the solution
is having that conversation
with your clinician.
It's just that videos help
spark the conversation
as we saw in our study.
AUDIENCE: But you don't have any
data on whether the video alone
is as effective or close to.
ANGELO VOLANDES: So we don't do
that intentionally because we
don't want people to
say, I could envision,
my worst nightmare, what
keeps me up at night,
is a surgeon-- I hate to
say surgeon-- who says, hey,
go watch this video.
Tell me what you want.
I don't want that.
I got into medicine because
I love talking to patients.
I hope my colleagues
feel the same.
Your other question.
AUDIENCE: OK.
The third question is
so do you routinely
have the conversation
at the revolving door
now in your practice?
ANGELO VOLANDES: In my
practice, absolutely.
And what's remarkable is
that it's not just me.
I'm proud to say that not only
in our health care system,
but all around the
country, what we see--
and this is the
work that the profit
does-- is people are
making this routine.
It's changing the
culture where part
of the responsibility
of being a good doctor,
a good clinician, is not only
asking what medications are you
on, what are your allergies,
and your past medical history,
but let's sit down and talk
about honoring and respecting
your choices if you
have a serious illness.
AUDIENCE: All right.
And the last question is
did Edward change his mind
about following the book?
Did he question the book ever?
ANGELO VOLANDES: So that's
a wonderful question.
Edward is a dear friend of mine.
Edward and I have both grown
through that experience.
In fact, part of our subsequent
code because we had many codes
together, Edward and I looked
at each other and we said,
you know what, we're both
committed to changing health
care.
And I'm very happy
to say that Edward
is one of our big supporters
in our nonprofit work
and actually has transformed
care in the city that he's at.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: You talked
about measuring
the effects this has on
what choices people made
and figuring out whether those
choices are followed through
on.
Did you also measure how
that actually affects
length of life,
quality of life, how
their friends and family feel
about what happened, and so on.
ANGELO VOLANDES: Yeah,
what a wonderful question.
So we are actually now,
with our other studies,
looking at those very
important questions.
What was the bereavement
experience for the family?
We often focus what's happening
on the patient but remember,
when the patient dies, it's
the family that experiences
that moment over and over.
So we are looking at things
like anxiety and depression
on family members, what we call
the bereavement experience.
And the other ones
that you wanted?
AUDIENCE: What effects
it has on the patient's
both length of life
and quality of life
and how they feel
about what happened.
ANGELO VOLANDES: Wonderful.
So we actually are
looking at survival.
Slowly we're seeing research.
In fact, one of the
big papers on this
came out in Mass General
Hospital and my colleagues
there, where they
looked at people
who chose early hospice care.
And what they found
in a randomized trial
compared to people who did
not choose hospice care,
was they actually lived longer.
That's a new finding.
And that's something
we are publicizing.
And what's happening
is-- this is
what we think is
going on-- people
actually live longer when
they feel that they're
in control of what's going on.
But going to the hospital
might be bad for you.
Medical errors that we
have in our health care
system, whether it's infection
rates or procedures that
are performed on people who
are critically ill, actually
might lead to earlier deaths.
This is a very
controversial thing
that we're trying
to publicize about.
And we tell people, do you
know that in numerous studies
now, people who choose
more comfort oriented
care with a life limiting
illness actually live longer.
And so we are looking at
that with our studies.
What happens to survival rates?
What happens to those
600 nursing homes?
What happens to folks
who decide I'd rather
stay in the nursing home.
I'd rather not get CPR or not
get aggressive life prolonging
interventions.
I want aggressive care.
But I want aggressive
care focused on my quality
of life and comfort.
We'll be following
that and it's really
transforming what's going
on in health care today.
Thank you.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You stopped
short of any discussion
of actually assisting patients
in their death process.
Can you discuss that issue?
ANGELO VOLANDES: Why does
this question always come up?
AUDIENCE: Because there's
always someone like me.
ANGELO VOLANDES: There's
always someone like you.
OK.
So let's be clear.
The book's about
advance care planning.
It's about what affects every
single person in our country
today.
It's about making
sure we're honoring
and respecting people's wishes.
The issue of-- I'm going to call
it for the variety of things--
today it's aid in dying.
Euthanasia, passive
assisted suicide,
whatever phrase you
want to call it,
is something
incredibly different.
I'm not a policy wonk.
I don't understand
all the issues.
But I will say two things
because this issue,
this question always comes up.
It's complicated.
It's really complicated.
And I will say first, in
our health care system
today, for the vast
majority of Americans,
we are not meeting their
needs for suffering and pain
and control of their illness.
And so the amount
of resources that we
have for hospice and
palliative care services
across the country is
clearly inadequate.
And so I'm really
focusing on trying
to make sure we have those
resources because the question
that I always have is if
we actually meet people
where they're at, if we actually
gave them control to not
be in pain and suffering, where
they feel that they are truly
at the center of care, I feel
that a lot of the issues that
come up during the debate about
aid in dying will disappear.
That's my personal opinion.
But I think the issue of aid
in dying is so complicated.
I'm not an expert on that.
I don't cover it in the book.
I'm sorry.
But I try my best to make
sure that people understand
that we do a horrible job
in health care today on just
meeting people where
they're at when
it comes to end of life care.
Because it's not
just-- even though I
call it end of life care,
it's not end of life care.
It's about good care.
It's not about a good death.
It's about good life.
We're all going to die.
I'm going to die some day.
And every good life
deserves a good ending.
So that's where I
want to meet people at
and I know that's an
unsatisfactory answer.
I'm asked it all the time.
And I try not to
deflect it too much
but I think it's complicated.
I honor and respect
people who debate
with me about this
question because I think
every patient has a story.
And I've been on
this book tour now
for a few weeks and
there's a lot of pain
and suffering out there.
And it's patients but
it's also family members
and everybody deserves
to have their voice.
We're just hoping
"The Conversation"
and the videos help everybody
have a voice at the table.
Thank you very much.
I really appreciate your time.